to do is we want to find a line that's
perpendicular meaning at a right angle
to the segment and cuts it in half
bisects it okay so what we're gonna do
is we're going to take our compass okay
so this is just a basic compass here
what you want to make sure is that these
two points come together you don't want
one to be like down here and there
they're going to be up there you want
him to come together at the end and so
what you're gonna do is you're gonna
open it up and what you want to do is
you want to make sure that you open it
up more than halfway if it's less than
halfway you're gonna have an issue you
want to make sure you open up more than
halfway it doesn't have to be exact but
we're gonna do is we're going to make an
arc below the segment and above the
segment like so okay and if you want
some students will just make a
continuous arc like like that but you
can separate the two arcs and then what
you're going to do is go from the other
endpoint okay like so and they're gonna
make two more arcs let me just make sure
we got it correct here so we've got this
arc and then we're gonna just rotate the
paper like this we're going to make
another arc above and below okay and
then what you're going to use you're
going to use those two points to draw a
line okay so those two points of
intersection right here and right here
and that's going to be your
perpendicular bisector okay there you go
so you can see that that's the right
angle 90 degrees and you can see that
it's cutting that segment in half so
this has been how to construct a
perpendicular bisector I'll see you in
the next video